We had 68,000 hospitalizations.
So the 4,000 number would be
a subset of that and I
don't know what information we
have that we haven't released
at this point you know no I
don't think there is any
information that we have that we
haven't released at this point.
But I just want to reiterate
once again that the policy that
the Department of Health put out
was in line directly with
the March 13 directive put out
by CDC and CNS that read and I
quote nursing homes should admit
any individuals from hospitals
where coded is president not
could shut that as President
Trump's CNS and CDC so I know
that there's been a lot
of discussion on this topic
there are over a dozen states
that did the exact same thing
many of whom were concerned
about hospital capacity
at the time everybody remembers
the projections were well
into the 140,000 hospital bed
range whereas we started out
with I think it was about 50,000
and
so obviously any death is
an unfortunate death but even
when you look at in comparison
to other states, New Jersey has
5,522 confirmed nursing home
deaths whereas New York has
3,094 Massachusetts 3,755
Connecticut 1,400 87 it's been
a national and international
tragedy that everybody has had
to grapple with and it is
something that we're trying
to learn from every day and move
forward Yeah I see let me just
let me just coming into the look
we're in a political environment
here I get it.
I understand it I'm a big boy I
can say all day long I refuse
to politicize this discussion
and I have not and I will not
because I represent Democrats
and Republicans and independents
and atheists and short people
and tall people and the politics
makes no difference to me I have
no political agenda I have no
political aspirations there's no
politics here the I can say
that,
but we're still in an election
year and people are still
playing politics and this is
a hyper partisan environment
to the extent people want
to politicize this issue
and Republicans are saying well
New York did this New York
followed
the president's agency's
guidance so that de politicizes
it what New York did was follow
what the Republican
administrations said to do
that's not my attempt
to politicize it it's my attempt
to d politicize it
so don't criticize the state
for following
the president's policy.